as you know i am a total beauty junkie
i love sharing my favorite products or
customizing the perfect beauty routine
and that's why i'm so excited for our
very first
beauty in a box segment
okay so we asked you to send us some of
your beauty dilemmas
so that we could craft the perfect care
package and deliver it
straight to your door today's beauty sos
came from
daniela take a look hi drew my name is
daniela i'm 40 years old
i live in illinois i am a working mom
with four kids i need some help with
makeup
i need a five minute routine that will
enhance the most features um because
five minutes is about as much time as i
have with four kids and working
also if you could help me with mascara i
hate putting it on
it smudges and i look like a raccoon
within an hour it's just
underneath my eyes so if i have to wear
it please teach me how to use it
thank you and i really need your help
daniela i have to tell you you are so
beautiful i've seen your video before
but as i'm re-watching it i'm just like
you're so pretty thank you that's a
very big compliment coming from drew
barrymore well
what i put together for you do you have
a box in front of you
we sent you some beauty products you do
okay all right this is beauty in a box
shall we open it together yes please
okay
so what i got for you first is
i love the company keels um and this is
a skin tone and uh beautifying bb
cream but it also has sunscreen do you
wear sunscreen
i do that's probably the only thing that
i'm very consistent about oh my god i'm
so proud of you and happy for you
because i'm terrible about it unless i'm
going into the sun
i always forget so tinted
moisturizers and light bb creams with
sunscreen are just great for daily wear
and they're going to be a really light
layer you can literally put it into your
hands
like a moisturizer and then do the pat
pat pat and then you'll go under the
eyes
and you can always add more you look
amazing
wow isn't it it's crazy
okay i am so pleased do you what do you
think do you like it
well it's nice because it's it's light
it feels really nice on it's
very moisturizing okay now next what i
got you
is this is a company called amazing
amazing concealer
um and this is for if you ever have more
sleepless nights or you're just a little
more exhausted or you get a blemish
and what's nice is that the pigment is
nice
and heavy so it'll cover up dark circles
or a spot
but it's very blendable on the edges
otherwise you're going to see the circle
so under my app
yeah just a teeny dot dot dot and then
you can work it in with your fingers
very minimal this is for those [ __ ]
keeper days when the kids
have exhausted you oh my god you look so
beautiful
i'm so excited i swear i feel like
i don't know i feel like like an artist
right now and like i'm painting you and
like i'm like look at this a painting
she's so beautiful
oh my god you really i'm so happy right
now because you are already so beautiful
and
i want things that will not take away
from your natural beauty
okay this one is actually from flower
beauty
it's called um gel crush and the reason
i love this
it's brand new for our company you take
it off it's great for the bag
i also love a good purse friendly makeup
when you have a foundation the size of
this you're probably not throwing it in
your purse
so this is dot dot dot dot dot dot
and a little smudge on the lips just so
if you want a pop of color you know you
can get it out of this
oh daniela you are looking so foxy
i'm so pleased right now i feel like a
proud peacock
is it too much or no no not at all
that's great and then
work it all over the lips like um
like a deodorant fell in love with a
lipstick and how to bake it
yes oh that just gave that perfect
little kick where it sort of picks up
your natural pigment
the thing that i care the most about
with flower beauty is that it will never
leave a woman hanging when we have a
formula
it never like gathers or goes in the
cracks the pigment just goes away
the hydration stays okay next from
flower i got you
our lash warrior and the reason i love
this is it looks like a weapon
because it is it is an amazing mascara
and it actually has a rubber wand
um which is gonna distribute through the
lash differently and it's gonna lead to
less
flakage i think you're doing a
phenomenal job
okay now at the end i put this in
special this is micellar water i
discovered this because all the people
in the fashion industry
for the runway fashion shows were using
this because they could take off all the
makeup in one felt swoop and it used to
only be available
in france and now my solar waters are
always on trend
so this is a garnier you can find this
anywhere
so when you're done with all of this you
want to put this
on the pad and you want to just take
everything off
and make it nice and clean and clear no
matter what you do
do not go to bed with your makeup on
no it's usually pretty easy because i
normally don't wear makeup but
no i do wash i do have a good cleansing
routine it's just some
it's just makeup i have a hard time with
it but this is something i can totally
do on my own
and quick with four kids thank you so
much
that's exactly the point natural
fast and absolutely beautiful you
already were and this just
enhances that and really the whole point
of
beauty is how you feel and if something
happens where it boosts the way you feel
that is the whole point as far as i'm
concerned
thank you so much this was great i feel
great thank you daniela
you are so gorgeous thank you for
[Music]
playing
you